je me sens comme une hormone je pourrai
dormir tellement quelques heures par
jour en été et hiver et culinaires un
moment de partage entre extraits de
lecture question et échangent des
collégiens ont eu l'occasion de
rencontrer colline pirée au triste de ma
fuite chez moi racontant l'histoire
d'anouk une collégienne de 14 ans un
roman qu'ils avaient eux mêmes choisis
dans le cadre des ateliers lire et
choisir c'était bien de rencontrer le
triste du livre qu'on a préféré entre
happy end et mahfoud chez moi et c'était
bien de lui poser des questions
on lui a fait des dessins vous des
cartes pour dire si on avait aimé les
passages du livre de son livre qu'on
avait bien aimé lire et choisir a été
mis en place depuis 2008 par les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines
plusieurs oeuvres coup de coeur sont
sélectionnés par les bibliothécaires
avant que les élèves ne les découvre et
ne les départage cette année c'est le
roman rapide de hann loyers qui
partagent l affiche avec ma fuite chez
moi l'objectif c'est de rignac 14
classes du territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines des classes de 5e afin de
les proposer des lectures ou qu'ils
puissent les lire et les choisir pour
aboutir à la rencontre du d'auteur donc
ce qui se passe notamment aujourd'hui et
toujours neuf c'est toujours différent
c'est toujours riche de pouvoir échanger
avec eux de pouvoir savoir aussi comment
ils ont reçu le livre qu'est ce qu'ils
ont qu'est ce qu'ils en retiennent
qu'est ce qu'ils ont aimé pas aimer
qu'est-ce qui les a touchés
qu'est-ce qui les questionne plusieurs
ateliers ont été organisés avant la
rencontre pour réaliser des dessins
choisir des extraits et préparer les
changes avec l'autriche de quoi
permettre aux élèves de maintenir un
lien avec la lecture